[Music]
foreign
father Greg changed my life father Greg
Boyle of Homeboy Industries if it wasn't
for that man I wouldn't be here today
right and so if people that don't know
who father Greg is Father Greg operates
the biggest gang non-profit organization
in the [__] world right it's been
around for almost 35 years he has worked
with just gang members all his life he
has buried close to maybe 250 to this
day as we speak
continuously bearing you get what I'm
saying continuously engaged right and
when he came into my life
and showed me love showed me [__] love
because love gets [__] thrown around
too much right when he just like did
what you're doing right now bro just
looking at me in the eyes and [__]
listening to me bro listening no one
listening bro bro everybody's crying for
help all these kids are crying for help
but nobody's [__] listening
and when he did that it was [__] and
it [__] me up it took so long to truly
understand that a person could just
genuinely just want to hear me do you
care about me
if that would have happened before in a
real way not coming in because a lot of
people get the [__] [__] up you can't
come in one day and think that the child
is going to be okay give them some good
words
if you gotta if you want to be committed
to this [__] to to the help you have
to be committed bro you know and give
yourself Seasons no one's saying don't
burn out because I've seen that [__]
doing this work why do this work I I'm
in the hood because I come from the hood
but it's it's you have to be willing to
[__] go you know and yes but no bro
if if someone would have been there I
think I would have because when it came
I did listen exactly can you tell me
about how he came into your life so I
get out of prison right and and for
those that are in Los Angeles all gangs
bro if you're from a gang you have a
connection to Homeboy Industries that
has been around black Mexican
Salvadorian Korean whatever gang you're
in Los Angeles real games right
that you have a direct connection
somehow someone came in and sure enough
when I came out of prison and it's that
right like you're you're a gang member
you have I'm tatted up I'm [__] on
parole like who's gonna then there's
that [__] right you want to talk about
[__] like bro here we go 200 dollars
I made this [__] [__] happen with 200
I'm sitting across you they [__] gave
me 200 I make this [__] happen that's
right that's what it is but you don't
have no understanding of like [__]
where to go right Homeboy Industries bro
yeah homeboys okay so but before you
even get that you get the 200 now you're
out you've done what you've done and we
haven't even talked about prison but you
get you you get out yeah
and and I think that that's right people
don't understand I mean bro No One's
Gonna hire you where do you go like what
like like to talk about that feeling
talk about that first week out no way
and and it's this you know what you did
your your my mom picks me up
and she picks you up and you know it but
it's the same [__] you're going back to
the same [__] that you came out of
and it's it's that you know you you have
my son's five I haven't seen him he
doesn't know me hmm
you know like [__] you're just like all
right [__] like like here I am right
here I am but I knew one thing that I
was clear-headed right
and um what do you mean I was I was
clear I was more clear than I have ever
been right like I I've seen life bro
like I remember the first stabbing that
I seen and I am with prison bro like I'm
on the yard for like a [__] week
boom part down thousands or thou over a
thousand and I look I'm like 21 when I
hit the yard bro I'm a young kids still
I'm damn [__] you know small but I
mean and I just see these [__]
they're like our age bro just [__]
[__] stabbing the [__] out of this
phone isn't it bro oh
y'all are down these
Fool's again
don't blow that fool I don't know if he
died or what and then you find out that
he was a [__] I think he was a child
molester or a rapist either or a bull
and this is how we're dealing with it
right
and you have to [__] you have to just
acknowledge it right you gotta
understanding it wrong but seeing what
the truth is you know and yeah bro that
[__] changed me bro that [__] [__]
prison changed me bro prison [__]
seeing homies just [__]
just overdosing on heroin Under the
Stairs type of [__] right just seeing
[__] your own turning the thing about
I did time in the South there you go
doing time in the South and doing time
in the north is completely different
because in the south
there's thousands of us bro we don't
have to be going at it with the Nortenos
up there right so it's I think it's a
setting like this when you're amongst
when all of you are there
and you don't have nobody to turn on to
turn tool you turn on each other
and that's what was happening and I knew
at that moment that I didn't know what
the [__] I wanted to do but I knew I
didn't want to do that you know and I
knew and at that time my crime people it
was crazy because my climbing demon
he's the only I took the rap nothing
happened to demon bro it was my but at
the end of it you know that's how it was
bro [__] but they thought that they
had me they're like [__] it we're gonna
give him life we don't need demon right
demon [__] gets out demon gets
paralyzed
also got shot bro and I would have been
there you get what I'm saying for like
these things are [__] happening in my
life these three years were you when you
found that out an Ironwood pocket the
letter they're like [__] sure enough
but I would have been there those are my
boys how long is that immediate do you
make that connection immediately bro
immediately immediately
it's gratitude but because I love these
[__] it's awesome like [__] dog
like would that have happened you know
could I have saved them you know just
part of you say [__] man you don't need
to be doing this you're out there you
don't need to be doing this or do you
not you're not there yet at that time
bro because even right now bro I cherish
every single relationship I had on my
name you know and I'm still in contact
with my boys that's so it's like yeah I
know now I know what positions I should
you know because it's that bro I'm like
bro I don't live like that no more right
so if you're living like that that
shit's gonna happen to you right I'm not
living like that but if I'm there with
you you know but yeah bro it's these
things that that just
[__] oh my pocket remember my best
friend
Sammy has been also like a life yeah I'm
I'm like eight months out bro on a new
bus so every time a new bus comes hits
the yard well homies are here right
making sure whoever's and we've got a
couple Eastsiders
so in prison it's very specific like
that it's not just about the county it's
specific of your area of course East
Side Right where's the east side car at
right we've got a couple new Insiders
and but I'm sure enough
wow just came down for Pelican Bay wow
either came down from the bay or from
Folsom but he has already been down 15
years
so it's like yeah bro and [__] yeah
it was it was it was a trip because he
he told me how that [__] went down
and and he and he pretty much tells me
like if if
things would have been different he
wouldn't he wasn't supposed to get life
bro
Sammy wasn't supposed to get life
that's that's pretty much what happened
bro
so what do you mean Sammy was supposed
to get life because so Sammy so what
happened on the case is that
he shot he shot this fool n and his mom
was in front of him right it was a whole
thing right homeboy had a gun though too
but when the whole deal happened another
gang member comes and takes the gun
so the self-defense [__] is gone
life
[Music]